au cours de cette édition du 7 8 je
recevrai aussi ce soir en plateau les
responsables du saint quentin en
yvelines rugby pour un match de gala ce
11 novembre au profit de l'association
laurette fugain pour l'instant sur le
plateau un bon soir à léon dubois
à 17 ans seulement passionné par
l'histoire plus particulièrement par la
première guerre mondiale vous organisez
même une exposition en ce moment dans le
département des yvelines on en verra
tout à l'heure quelques images une
exposition de circonstance puisque le 11
novembre ce sera la commémoration de
l'armistice de cette guerre de 14-18
pourquoi cette passion pour ce conflit
alors cette passion à l'aîné quand
j'étais en quatrième à cette passion qui
prenant ça me prend du temps mais c'est
passionnant de voir quatre heures
d'exposition tous les retours que je
peux avoir
vous avez fait des expositions voilà je
fais et collectionner des objets
d'autres collectionnent les objets sur
cette période et au delà de la
collection j'essaye de les remettre
l'histoire en avant voilà c'est à dire
que l'objet appuyé le témoignage
historique l'objet appuyé le témoignage
historique témoignage historique est le
message que voulait faire passer juste
c'est un message de transmission c'est
un message de devoir de mémoire j'essaye
de transmettre aux plus jeunes qui
peuvent paraître moins intéressés par ce
conflit que les plus anciens ce que
cette horreur cette grande boucherie
comme disaient les traditions c'est un
peu atypique justement les autres jeunes
que vous connaissez mon copain un
camarade qui réagissent comme en mai
pour bien ils m'aident
imed imeda donc vous réussissez déjà à
transmettre auprès de auprès des plus
jeunes c'était le but est bien sûr des
écoles vient de visiter mon exposition
et mes amis viennent voilà je leur fais
des visites se sont arrêtés un petit peu
sur cèze sur cette idée sur cette
passion et qu'est ce qui vous fascine
autant qu est ce qui vous intéresse
autant ça a commencé en 4e vous nous
l'avez mais c'est finalement pas si
longtemps mais pourquoi ces très jeunes
de s'intéresser dès la 4e à ce point à
cette période de distance c'est vrai
c'est vrai en fait ce qui m'a fasciné
c'est pouvoir faire revivre la mémoire
de dom
en fait voilà c'est dans cette
exposition c'est bien ce que je présente
c'est que je met l'homme au coeur de la
grande guerre j'essaye de faire revivre
à travers les objets je fais des
recherches dans les archives et ça me
permet de faire revivre la mémoire de
ces hommes qui sont qui ont été tués ou
qui ont combattu sur sur le fond de
14-18 c'est lié à l'histoire de votre
famille aussi en partie puisque j'ai des
objets de mon arrière arrière grand père
que j'ai retrouvé une pince havre des
documents cela se trouvait après ou
qu'on vous à gauge y retrouverez était
dans la famille en fait je commençais à
m'intéresser à cette période et j
retrouver ces objets donc ça m'a ça m'a
permis de continuer en fait voilà
affirmé cherche donc objets d'époque
témoignages également tout ce qui tourne
tout ce qui a attrait à autour de ce
conflit vous le réunissez-vous le
collectionner pour ensuite l exposé
c'est difficile de se procurer des
objets des témoignages de cette époque
oui c'est difficile mais on y arrive à
travers les
c'est la recherche on est les brocantes
brocanteurs antiquaires tout ça mais on
y arrive
et bien c'est un coup c'est un coup que
c'est un coup mais bon ça c'est faut
savoir se ça négocie aussi on négocie
entre entre collectionneurs on
s'arrangerait pour ensuite effectivement
pouvoir présenter tous alors
d'exposition on a vu les images de cette
exposition qui a lieu à fontenay en ce
moment je précise également que ce sera
ouvert le dimanche c'était la mairie de
fontenay s'est ouvert ce dimanche 11
novembre lors s'est ouvert ce dimanche
11 novembre le matin simplement jusque
12h30 à ceux qui après les
commémorations voudraient découvrir
votre exposition ce sera l'occasion et
puis sinon on renvoie vers le site
internet de la municipalité de fontenay
pour connaître tous les horaires de
cette exposition à découvrir il ya un
fil conducteur à cette exposition
comment l'homme a réagi face à la
terreur des combats c'est vrai très
structuré sa nouvelle structure est
juste un amoncellement d'objets voilà
c'est ça c'est ce qui fait la différence
entre la collection est vraiment la
recherche c'est que ces objets ils ont
un fil conducteur qui est l'évolution de
l'état d'esprit du soldat entre 14 et 18
j'ai vraiment essayé de de sensibiliser
les gens à cette guerre va travers le le
témoignage est l'état d'esprit des
soldats vraiment vous êtes étudiant en
histoire voilà en première année à 50 50
ans on avait une à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines il
ya d'autres périodes de l'histoire qui
vous fascine tout me fasse il m'a
vraiment tout m'intéresse mais j'ai bien
sûr donc j'ai une personne ma période
préférée c'est 14-18 puisque je peux
avoir ce témoignage matériel et la suite
pour vous alors c'est quoi professeur
d'histoire à je ne sais pas répond non
c'est là dessus que je m'intéresse à
beaucoup de choses
je participe à un séminaire au ministère
de la défense sur la danse 18
je suis très engagé dans ma vie qui met
beaucoup je suis très ouvert vous
intervenez aussi dans des classes mais
ce jeu vous allez devenir éventuellement
professeurs mais vous intervenez déjà
auprès des plus jeunes j'interviens
auprès des plus jeunes qui viennent à
l'exposition et j'interviens aussi hors
expositions dans des classes pour dans
mon lycée notamment je suis intervenu
pour un ânon des objets pour expliquer
toute cette toute cette période
je vous demandais tout à l'heure comment
réagissent et les plus jeunes mais
comment réagissent les plus anciens
aussi lorsque vous présentez est ce que
vous êtes
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un moment où vous
dites est ce que je vais être crédible
est ce qu'on va m'écouter parce que je
suis très jeune cette période est très
très loin pour moi alors tout cas est-ce
que c'est l'accueil que vous avez
quelquefois pas vraiment pas vraiment en
fait en général les gens sont sont très
contents parce qu'ils apprennent des
choses c'est pas moi qui apprend des
choses aux autres c'est les objets qui
que je mets en avant qu'il ya qui
apprennent des choses
voilà donc les joueurs sont en général
très très content de voir effectivement
que ça intéresse dès le plus jeune âge
il ya un site internet que vous avez mis
en place il ya quelques temps
oui il ya une devise dessus on peut
peut-être appeler çà comme çà
collectionner ces sauvegardes et
l'histoire voilà c'est ça c'est tout là
tout le sens de la collection ans et
sait pouvoir conserver ces objets pour
pour transmettre aux générations futures
ce témoignage est utile et qu'on peut
utiliser ses ressources matérielles et
ensuite justement cette exposition est
itinérante en est ce qu'il ya dans
twilight 2 prévu alors il ya des dates
prévues dans les deux sèvres
voilà c'est à dire que il ya une
délégation qui vient lundi 12 novembre
pour pourvoir un peu l'exposition que
j'ai organisé et qui sera intéressé pour
qu'elle tourne en tout les deux scènes
vous imaginer ouvrir un musée peut-être
eu dans votre ville par exemple non je
n'agis je n'imagine pas ouvrir de musée
j'essaye d'être up ce musée ça reste
fixe j'essaye vraiment d'aller vers les
gens pour retransmettre le plus possible
il faut que cette exposition aller à la
rencontre des gens que vous soyez sur
fontenay le fleury aux alentours ont
même un petit peu plus loin n'hésitez
pas à vous y rendre vous y allez
régulièrement pour intervenir a expliqué
les objets j'y suis quasiment tous les
jours sauf le mercredi et le lundi matin
puis lé court aussi à l'université il ya
les cours à l'université
il va bien y aller forcément voilà merci
léon dubois tête insisté sur ce plateau
cette exposition en ce moment à fontenay
le fleury l'homme dans la grande guerre
c'est à la municipalité donc de cette
commune s'est ouvert également ce
dimanche 11 novembre à l'occasion
forcément des commémorations autour de
l'armistice merci merci nous allons
passer à présent à la chronique de
l'écho avec alice gastines auparavant
retour avec valérie auribeau et anthony
rech sur les ateliers énergies
renouvelables de la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux des
ateliers pour toute la famille les défis
du renouvelable
ce matin-là parents et enfants avaient
décidé de les relever
à la maison de l'environnement de magny
les hameaux petits et grands étaient
attablés autour des trois ateliers
solaire éolien et thermique
ce matin on avait envie de montrer ou de
doute qu'à d'apprendre aux enfants de
façon très simple quels sont les
énergies renouvelables que l'on peut
utiliser pour essayer de trouver
d'autres solutions que le pétrole ou les
énergies fossiles
nos ingénieurs d'un jour ont pu bâtir
leur première maison en carton avec
panneaux photovoltaïques des véhicules
hydraulique ou air comprimé et
participer à la course de voiture au
début ils viennent vraiment plus pour
jouer qu'autre chose mais très vite ils
comprennent que ça une utilité et que ça
permet justement de remplacer des
énergies fossiles par des énergies
simple et d'énergies naturelles qui sont
le soleil le vent et l'eau
l'eau le vent nous désormais plus de
secret pour ces apprentis écolo les
petits comme les grands je pourrais
citer un super ateliers pour les enfants
si bien pour les enfants que les adultes
sur un an ils ont fait beaucoup de
choses une maison regarder tu peux
décrire mais ce que tu as fait un petit
peu oui
réaliser une voiture et une voiture
avec qui marche avec de l'air avec à
moulins à eau et la moto en fait l'info
souffler dans l'appareil et après on
rase au ballon ça donne une impulsion
après la belle sort et ça fait avancer
la voiture prochaine atelier le 15
décembre pour des décorations de noël à
base de matériaux de récupération